the introduction to bioinformatics
course is an introduction to the field
of bioinformatics or the intersection of
informatics and biology it speaks about
the opportunities that come with the
available big data and methods for its
analysis in research and industry
including healthcare agriculture
environmental sciences public health and
more biology is rapidly acquiring the
character of a data science billions of
data points on genes proteins and other
molecules are compiled in large files
and systematically studied analyzing
this data will lead to more knowledge
and understanding about living organisms
including human health
biotechnology crops and livestock
production this course will give an
overview of bioinformatics for students
biologists and clinicians the influx of
data associated methodologies and data
driven research makes bioinformatics for
Life Sciences as prominent as the
emergence of computers for the tech
industry this course is divided into
three sections
introduction to big data bioinformatics
bioinformatics in healthcare and
translational bioinformatics all of
these sections can be completed in under
two hours of study the course will
provide important information
terminology and perspectives from
experts on this exciting field there are
three sections and a quiz at the end the
course can be taken by anyone without
any special prior knowledge in related
fields after signing up and completing
the profile you will be able to see your
progress and notice points accumulating
under your profile based on this
activity you can see how you master
important skills and acquire
certificates of completion for this
course and other ones that you will find
on the edu that t - bio data info
platform as an introductory course you
will also learn about a project-based
approach to learning bioinformatics we
take datasets from high impact
publications and convert them into
online learning experiences each
subsequent course you will take will
have a practical application that
demonstrates
how bioinformatics can be used these
projects will fall under certain
specializations like oncology
neuroscience agro tech and others the
specializations provide domain expertise
and explain basic bioinformatics
concepts related to that subject as a
result anyone starting on this journey
in bioinformatics can start developing a
project of their own by seeing how
experts analyze their data and achieve
research results you can start
developing a research question of your
own identify the appropriate type of
data and planning your analysis this
introductory course leads into multiple
courses and projects that can serve as a
springboard into the world of
bioinformatics in subsequent courses we
will be utilizing the T bio info
platform to process big datasets this
platform is built for multi-omics
integration and analysis of structured
data with advanced methods like machine
learning and mathematical modeling after
you set up your account make sure to try
out the analytical platform you can do
so by filling out a form on server dot t
- bio that info the analytical platform
will provide hands-on experience for
anyone to apply to learn skills -
interesting datasets with color coded
logical maps explanation of methods
detailed input and output formats and
reproducible workflows this course
provides a broad overview but it is
structured to offer significant depth
even for the experienced users after
completing this short introduction you
will be inspired to continue learning
about the exciting field of
bioinformatics this program has been
tested in multiple universities around
the world and reviewed by experts in the
field of bioinformatics we are excited
that you joined so let's start learning